most people who visit LA come to see
something like this but icon to see
stuff like this this grimy part of LA is
Hoth or in California it's not a lot to
look at but it is where all the
aerospace companies are located the old
ones the new ones like SpaceX and then
even newer companies like the one will
get a visit today that are trying to
build rockets faster and cheaper than
ever before relativity and its two
founders Tim and Jordan have a plan to
make rockets faster and cheaper than
anyone else to do this they're looking
to build every part of the rocket its
engine its fuel tanks and its body with
giant 3d printers the relativity is
building the first autonomous rocket
Factory and launch service the basic
problem that these guys are trying to
solve is that Rockets remain very
expensive and hard to make SpaceX is the
cheapest most nimble rocket company
around and it charges about sixty
million dollars per launch so raw
materials and propellant are five
percent or less of the cost eighteen and
ninety percent are labor and then the
rest are kind of operational fees and
things on the launch side and so it's
really how do you take that raw material
make a rocket that's actually going to
work and then fly it in the most
efficient way we believe autonomous
manufacturing which is how we think of
3d printing really gets us to that point
where we save a lot of money at this
point you may be thinking tir'd God not
another 3d printing thing but here's the
deal relativity wants to sell its
rockets for 10 million dollars each
hitting that low low every day price can
only happen if machines replace humans
on the factory floor and to put a novel
twist on its 3d printers relativity is
making its own metal with this guy's
house
so I'm Sam Tomlin I'm the lead materials
engineer at relativity I've been in
charge of sourcing alloys
alloys and tailoring all of our
processes to get the best material
properties out of all the parts that
we're printing we are looking at the
structure of the materials on a micron
level and so we want to see ductility
strength for mobility all that stuff
[Music]
it's insane to try and build a rocket
it's even more insane to have to build
the world's largest 3d printer along the
way but there's some reason to think
that these two guys in their 20s have a
chance at succeeding the founders both
built rockets at USC after school Tim
took a job at Jeff businesses rocket
company Blue Origin where he specialized
in 3d printing rocket parts Jordan ended
up at SpaceX working on engines
relativity has only been in business for
a couple of years and hopes to fly its
first rocket in 2021 they've raised
about 10 million dollars in funding and
count Mark Cuban is one of their
investors tell me how you first made
your pitch to Mark Cuban what did them
what it was the subject line in that
email the subject line was 3d printing
an entire rocket space - sexi any bet
within five minutes like his email game
is crazy with a bit of luck okay with a
few thousand metric tons of luck these
guys hope not just to make rockets but
to alter the course of how and where
humans make all kinds of stuff so we
think a fully automated 3d printed
factory with intelligent manufacturing
with a small footprint is what we need
when we're going out to Mars and
colonizing outside of space so
relativity's long-term mission is we
want a 3d print the first rocket on Mars
this is like a stepping stone towards
this future to get to this you know
million people living and working on
Mars you're gonna need an industrial
technology to complement that being able
to send these machines and 3d printers
will really leverage and augment what
they're
the setup early on
you
you